par exemple de la pluie et des
températures raisonnables un peu de
répit ce jeudi pour les élèves de
l'école de la Maladière car depuis
quelques jours les classes situées à
l'étage de ce bâtiment souffre près de
32 degrés dès le matin y étudier et
parfois impossible comme en témoigne
parents et enfants
la
chaleur ardoise on est allé dehors pour
prendre l'air vu qu'il faisait trop
chaud dans la classe
quand il rentre aussi le soir c'est sûr
qu'on n'est pas l'abri d'un enfant qui
fasse un malaise c'est sûr mais c'est
que ce devant qu'ils prennent donc quand
tu es derrière tu m'as vraiment chaud
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a des gens parfois qui saignent du
nez le problème n'est pas nouveau sur le
site internet de l'établissement les
rapports du Conseil d'école se répètent
d'année en année voici celui de 2023 les
gros problèmes de chaleur de l'été
dernier n'ont pas été réglées l'idéal
ventilateur au plafond ou plusieurs
ventilateurs par classe demande faite
pas de retour un rapport qui ressemble
beaucoup à celui de 2020 mieux mais
encore de gros problèmes de chaleur
l'été dernier l'idéal ventilateur au
plafond ou de ventilateurs par classe
la mairie elle affirme ne pas avoir été
alerté et promet une étude nous allons
poser des sondes effectivement pour un
relevé de température sur les deux
classes qui sont concernées dès la
semaine prochaine les ventilateurs bien
entendu nous les mettons à disposition
des groupes scolaires quand c'est
nécessaire donc il y aura des
ventilateurs en attendant une nouvelle
isolation promise dans toutes les écoles
d'igenaises à l'horizon 2030 mais la
maladie ne fait pas partie des chantiers
prioritaires